okay now something very weird
is happening in financial markets shares
in the loss making it's important to say
loss making us video game retailer
gamestop are now worth
15 times as much as they were at the
beginning of the year
now part of the reason is that amateur
investors
have been piling into stock in an effort
to target hedge funds
which have big bets that gamestop shares
will
fall in value now this battle between
amateur
and professional investors is creating
huge price swings which are now
spreading to other stocks
like the uk education publishing company
pearson
gary stevenson joins us now as an
economist and former city trader
um gary tell us what is going on here
good afternoon
so i think to understand what's
happening you need to have a little bit
of broad context basically obviously
please
we've had a massive economic crash but
um if you were to look at the stock
markets you you wouldn't know it
especially if you look at the american
stock markets this is something
soaring right there's there's been an
explosion i mean i think it's up sort of
80 90
since the lows in march and this is just
phenomenal when you consider you know
what has happened to the economy
and the situation of a lot of american
workers
or in many cases people who want to work
is they're sitting at home
they're not able to work because of the
coronaries crisis they're not making
money and they haven't had quite the
same levels of support that we've had
here
and they're just watching these stock
markets fly through the roof
and you know some people are calling it
a k-shaped recovery i think that's what
it is really
stock markets are flying through the
roof here in england we're seeing more
happening in
property markets but ordinary people
they've lost their jobs and lost their
incomes and
people are starting to think well it's
about time you get involved in this and
now you're seeing
ordinary people you know sitting at home
on reddit which is this internet
messaging board
said we want to get involved and we want
some of that too we don't want that just
to go to the wealthy
stockholders and um it's it's been crazy
so they've all turned into this one-stop
gamestop which has gone up i think
one thousand five hundred percent in
about two weeks it's nearly bankrupted
the u.s hedge fund
and it it just is a phenomenal story but
i think this is what happens when
when governments basically try and fix
an economic crisis by pouring loads and
loads of money
and not dealing with the underlying
issues that are happening so
tell me what it is just let's get back
to basics gary
about short selling this is all about
short selling yes
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah um so basically
uh short selling is a way that um
an ordinary person or more often a
professional investor can basically try
and make money on the price of a stock
or anything else uh falling obviously if
a pr if a stock's gonna go up it's
pretty simple you do you go out you buy
the stock it goes up you sell it
so how do you make money from a stock
price going down uh well you can't sell
something you don't own
so what these people have to do is they
go out and they borrow a stock
then they sell it and they hope that
they can buy it back a week down the
line two weeks down the line
at a cheaper price and make money on it
falling um so
i think basically what caused this um
what caused these
redditors these people on the internet
to choose gamestop is they saw that
certain hedge funds had put massive
short positions on gamestop because
because actually they thought it was a
weak company and they thought well if
rightly so
right i mean they've done the analytics
they could see that it had been falling
and falling and falling it was a
retailer
it had it wasn't an online company it
was a retailer so
obviously malls are closed et cetera
captioning not
so they were short available it um but
these guys are ready and you know i
would love to know who initiated it um
they looked at it and said well these
guys have actually got really big short
positions
if we buy all the stock then these guys
who need to borrow the stock
in order to short sell it they won't be
able to short sell anymore and then
we can push the price up and then those
people who've gotten the price going
down
they will then have to buy at the higher
prices because they they can't keep a
short if you can't borrow the stock you
can't keep it sure
so this is what is known in financial
lingo as a classic short squeeze and um
it's happened many times in history
there's a big short squeeze in gold in
the 80s where people just try and
buy up to force short sellers to close
their positions at exorbitantly high
prices and
phenomenally it has worked and you know
there's one guy on the
i actually look at this reddit messaging
board it's called wall street bets
there's one guy and he claims to have
turned
50 000 into 47 million dollars which is
um
quite phenomenal to be honest and uh
certain hedge funds are not happy so
hedge funds have lost money but um
it really is a phenomenal story um
um so gary is this a case of who blinks
first
or essentially the small investors have
won this round
uh i think they might have won the
battle but the war continues
my concern is really you know what's
happened over the last couple of years
and you know i get messages from a lot
of people um telling me you know how can
i make money on the internet how can i
make money and
when i talk to these people often what
you find is um they're worried that
just just working a job is not going to
get them financial security you know
we've reached a situation where work
doesn't work
you know my background is i come from
quite a poor background but i made a lot
of money in the city essentially
gambling you know and we've reached a
situation now where
gambling on the stock markets can get
you money that just working an ordinary
job
can't get you so there's a lot of people
out there trying to make money on this
um but my concern is
at some point this game stop it it will
fall because it's massively overvalued
now all short squeezes end
my concern is that people who are
struggling because
the economic system is not working for
them work isn't working for them
they're going to be dragged into this
and they are going to quite possibly be
the ones holding this stock at the time
it collapses which inevitably it will
collapse so
some people have made huge amounts of
money on this some people have lost huge
amounts of money on this
but there will be more losses to come
when the people who are holding it
for you know this is my worry that
extends to other things such as bitcoin
such as tesla
mad online crazes as it were where
ordinary
ordinary investors ordinary people are
buying these things because they see
this online hype
they're getting pumped up by just pure
mania and when they collapse
my worry is who is going to be left
holding the baby when these things fall
gary stevenson thank you as well great
to speak to you both about this
fascinating story
i look forward to seeing how it develops